Like most other wedding in history, all British
royal weddings begin with:
the engagement.
But unlike regular weddings, these ones involve
an elaborately choreographed event that will
be watched by an audience of millions.
One of the first decisions a couple makes
is deciding where to actually do the thing.
If they’re really into history and tradition, there’s
really only one choice:
“From the solemnity of the abbey”
But not this time.
The big change is this wedding between Prince
Harry and Meghan Markle,
You don't have all the ambassadors from all
the different countries, you don't have heads
of state coming to this wedding.
One reason is because the Chapel Windsor can
only take 600 people and therefore there simply
isn't space.
But it's also clearly the desire of Prince
Harry and Meghan Markle to have a more informal
wedding.
At around two months before the big day, the
Lord Chamberlain’s office sends out individually
handcrafted invitations.
There’s flowers and fittings and the entirety of the city
to prepare.
While the bride and groom head to sleep in
different homes —
spectators who want a decent view of the public
processions will be sleeping outside.
And just a few hours later,
Some have traveled hundreds or even thousands of miles
and they camped out overnight to get a prime position along that procession route.
The general rule of royal weddings is the
the less important you are, the earlier you
arrive, and the farther back you sit.
If you’re there representing a charity, if
a member of the armed forces, or a celebrity,
you’re relegated to the nave of the church,
which means you might not even get to see
the actual ceremony.
Close friends of the bride and groom and other
guests will head in at least an hour and a
half before.
Most of the time it is: groom up at the front.
The royal procession comes in order In order
of precedence, which means the more junior
royals come first and
last comes the Queen and her husband Prince Philip.
Lots of fanfare as they come
and then the bride turns up.
When the bride arrives, the details of the
dress are finally revealed after months of
top secrecy.
I am beside myself. This is such a fashion moment, I can't tell you.
And regardless of who the designer is, she’ll
be wearing white and will carry a sprig of
myrtle in her bouquet, which symbolizes love
and marriage — both of which are trends
started by Queen Victoria.
The bride’s tiara is almost always the “something
borrowed,” likely from one of the family’s
collections of jewels.
Since 1923, the ring placed on the bride’s
finger is always made from Welsh gold —
Elizabeth and Diana’s rings even came from the same
nugget.
The ceremony's performed by the Archbishop of Canterbury
and only takes about an hour.
Towards the end, the bride, groom, and their
two witnesses
go into a private room
to sign the registrar.
At that point the wedding is sanctified in
law, as it was sanctified by religious service
a few minutes previously.
Officially married, the bride and groom exit,
closely followed by the Procession of the Queen.
If there's any heart that hasn't been run over by her today,
it can kindly surrender now.
There’s a good chance you’ll hear “Pomp
and Circumstance” around this time — although
Americans associate it with high school graduations,
it was originally written for the coronation
of King Edward VII.
The bride and groom will likely make their
way into the open 1902 State Landau for the
official carriage procession around the city
— that’s when the crowds who have been
waiting for hours, or possibly days, will get
their first look at the royal couple.
This usually concludes with the iconic appearance
on the Buckingham Palace balcony —
on which Diana and Charles were the first
to kiss.
The kiss is a critical moment in the entire
royal wedding ceremony.
You don't just throw it away in the middle
of church.
It has to be seen live by hundreds of thousands
of peoples.
And just in case anyone had missed it,
Prince William suggests one more kiss.
Because Meghan and Harry’s wedding is 20
miles outside of London, their first public
kiss as a married couple will have to happen someplace else.
Afterwards, the wedding party takes official photos,
and ceremony guests gather for the “wedding breakfast,"
complete with a traditional fruit
cake.
Though in the past the bride and groom would
change clothes and depart for their honeymoon
directly afterwards,
current royals have gone for a more modern
approach with a real party.
And they won’t be the only ones celebrating.
It is generally seen as an excuse to have
a good time and somewhat buttoned up Brits
who don't really have a good time in public
that much,
let their hair down and enjoy themselves
in the middle of their street.
At that point it’s a pretty normal wedding
reception — although normal ones don’t
generally include (rumoured) performances
by Elton John and the Spice Girls.
The royal couple will head off for the honeymoon
— which is almost certainly within the British Commonwealth,
while the rest of the country nurses a hangover.
As they leave far behind them,
an exhilarated, exhausted London,
for them, as for any newlyweds,
the adventure is just about to begin.